morning to see this rumbles on and on
doesn't it yes it does and uh it seems
to me that the police will have had
further complaints and seen further
Evidence particularly about that event
at conservative HQ and are going to
investigate it so let's hope that they
can get on with it and get to the bottom
of what happened if any
if anybody have broken the rules should
they be stopped from having a peerage
well my view is about anybody who is
implicated in uh this sort of thing that
it's up to them to determine not to
decide whether or not they should accept
an honor once the system has started it
is very difficult to stop it if if all
the vetting has taken place but if there
is fresh information and important fresh
evidence that really costs more than a
cloud over that individual's reputation
then they should seriously think at the
very least about not accepting a peerage
or accepting an honor because I think
the honor System needs to be kept as it
needs to have integrity and these sort
of events and incidences can undermine
that and that's why I think individuals
need to think very carefully what's the
role of the Prime Minister in that
though can he not block whether someone
is well I think I think
um the Prime Minister I think is faced
with a difficult situation because there
will have been a process that he won't
have been involved with and if you're
like he's present with you know the the
decision made by by others by previous
prime minister well indeed and I think I
don't I don't think Russia can be blamed
for any decision that his predecessor
made and you know it's a fatal complete
by the time it comes to him so it is
really up to the individual's concerns
to look look in the mirror and decide
whether or not they they should accept
Awards sorry
um I don't know whether you managed to
catch any of the Prime Minister in front
of the liaison committee yesterday which
just to explain for our viewers is the
chairs of all of the other Committees of
MPS across the road in the House of
Commons
um he was Under Fire on more than one
occasion how do you think he did I I
listened to some of it it was an hour
and a half session I think
um I think this is a prime minister on
top of his brief he clearly knows the
detail and is able to answer with
authority on a range of issues I think
it's really healthy that he goes in
front of such committees regularly to
answer as he does uh you know every
virtually every week in the House of
Commons and some of the criticism was
being made that he wasn't turning up to
prime minister's questions well I don't
think you should two in a row yeah but
look I mean there's an important
important event for the NHS today which
you know he's been asked to attend he
didn't plan that and then there's the
NATO Summit I really think you know two
prime ministers questions out of many
many dozens in a year is hardly skipping
his responsibility to answer for uh his
actions he's accountable daily through
the media and through the glare of uh uh
the House of Commons and I think you
know the British system means the prime
ministers are amongst the most
accountable in the world and the Prime
Minister on the phone well I wonder is
that goodness yeah that's probably my
wife actually
there we go she's not he's on the Telly
at the moment hang on a second he'll
call you back you say that although you
know it was pointed out during that
liaison committee briefing that he's
been missing uh several of his targets
well yes and you know at the beginning
of the year it was said that you know he
picked some easy meteor by picking five
targets that he could meet through for
example inflation and the truth is he
was always going to be a tough uh Road
and you know he's accepted I think the
challenge which I think is right and it
is tough because once inflation gets
into the system it's difficult to get
out but what I like about the prime
minister is that he's got a
single-minded purpose that he wants to
achieve what I think are relevant goals
for the British people are the cost of
living couldn't be more important
growing the economy couldn't be more
important uh do you think anything down
the waiting list yes but he's not
managed to do that couldn't be more
important well I think we've heard I
think rightly and honestly from from
Health ministers that it may well be
that enlists will rise before they start
to come down I know that in the Health
Service everybody's working as hard as
they can we've had some disruption of
course with strikes I very much hope
that we can get through that phase in
that period because I know that
everybody in the Health Service wants to
serve patients and and get on with the
job that they are so dedicated to doing
and stopping the boats well
okay it's not just about Rwanda it's
about a whole range of initiatives for
example the prime ministers deal with
Albania I know the government are
talking to the Italians I think if they
can reach it but those numbers have gone
up as well haven't they yeah and I think
in the summer you know they they do and
and everybody looks at that and gets
quite rightly concerned and angry about
a floating of the law and a floating of
the rules which is why again he hasn't
sort of shied away from grasping that
nettle and trying to do something about
it you know I I looked at the Rwanda
decision last week it's clear that what
happened was that some of the judges
didn't think there was enough evidence
to show that Rwanda was a so-called safe
country uh one judge did I very much
hope that if the matter goes to the next
level to the Supreme Court that there
will be an abundance of evidence to show
that Rwanda is a safe country that the
project can go ahead I know that you are
a cricket fan do you agree with the
Prime Minister that he wouldn't want
England to win by cheating
well I was there I know and I wouldn't
have appealed that the initial uh
decision I wouldn't have asked for it's
England's fault well no no no I I think
that well I think that it's a test match
I think everybody is on their medal to
win I think that what we saw might have
been considered by summer sharp but it
wasn't cheating and I certainly think
that Australian players do not deserve
to be barracked as they were some of
them were in The Pavilion by uh
individual members of MCC I thought that
was wrong I don't think that's within
the spirit of cricket I very much hope
that as we get to headingley which is of
course coming uh thick and fast that we
see a competitive game and we see the
sort of spirit that Ben Stokes invoked
when he really got to grips with it and
made one of the most memorable uh 150s
I've ever seen in test cricket